in five four three two one
hello everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain podcast I'm
your host David so we have your other
hosts for every Thursday Jo Jitsu
[ __ ] caller hello everybody how is
everybody's week how are all of you
doing today we are going to you know we
we started taking in requests about
personal issues because I found out this
is what people like a lot and it opens
up a lot of great conversation sometimes
the podcast will be random but sometimes
they'll be about very very specific
subjects so today we are going to go
through a lot of patreon people had
their stuff already answered so we're
gonna go into the emails and kind of
address personal issues that you guys
have that you guys want us to talk about
once again this is not really per se
advices these are just like suggestions
and thoughts and then kind of want to
hear in the comments below if you guys
are all watching on YouTube about your
two cents about the situation to see
what you guys can add to the
conversation because here that is very
very [ __ ] important I like going into
the comments section and arguing with
the fans it's perfect that today it was
pretty fun it is the best yep let's go
argh you guys here we go first one this
person wants to be kept anonymous so
even better we will keep this person
anonymous for sure we will call her um
we'll call her Jenna that's not her name
mmm Jenna okay gargles Jenna gargles so
Jenna says this Jenna gargles this
question is about a tough subject that I
need help with
I tried counseling but it hasn't worked
either the counselor wasn't right for me
or I haven't been in the right mindset
at at meeting them if possible can I
please stay anonymous of course on April
6 2009 teen I was wow this one's pretty
deep
she was uh sexually assaulted and raped
damn man you know it's I mean before we
even go to like do too deep in don't
make me sad I'll tell you this though I
know it's amazing how many female
females a little derogatory let's say
how many women I know that have gone
through this type of [ __ ] like at an
early age
it's [ __ ] unreal oh yeah like I was
surprised that some of my friend
I never would have thought yeah it's so
molested it's [ __ ] crazy and it's you
know like I'm not sure what age will
figure on this though but um like it
happened to a lot of my friends at a
very young age and it's just like with
em where they're deep at the most
helpless stage in their life and and and
it's like what the [ __ ]
like what do you do when it starts to
manifest in these negative things when
they as an adult I don't want to be
insensitive but me and my friends
molested each other I mean like it's
different when you touch each other with
the fudge you guys do we after I
remember one time after we were gonna
pull me and my friend we were told to
change and then he he stuck out his dick
and he started walking over and then I
grabbed my dick and I started walking to
him and we said saw pie and then we
started making seem like we made those
noises it's like that's so funny beside
them I don't know if we call that mother
station but that's for sure like kids
are like this is a dick you got a dick
let's play dicks but then that the the
tip rubbing felt good though so we just
kept going
that's your first gay experience and you
don't even [ __ ] know dude that's
pretty gay yeah but like we were like
Bobby Lee and his sakes or something
it's like Bobby Lee and [ __ ] sucking
dick with the sucking his best friend's
dick not that his friend was gay though
and so he's asked him for it I feel like
he was tricked into sucking his dick
yeah cuz I don't think it happened the
other way around I think he just got his
dick sucked oh he was tricked oh my god
it's just so funny it's like oh well how
old were you when you got a swordfight
like six or something damn I can't
remember doing anything with my dick
that made me feel good at that age
really mm-hmm I would [ __ ] do all
kinds of [ __ ] my neighbor she she was
she's so crazy she had this thing where
she always had to see somebody's dick
what we would all show her our dick
Lola she she was around okay you say
major like eight or nine though at that
we were older she just wanted to see
like everyone's dick and then she had
this little kind of like Playhouse thing
and then um she would ask us if she
could see it and then we would pull it
out what the [ __ ] but like she wouldn't
touch it or anything she just wanted to
see like childhood curiosity it's like
it's different it's not mine I guess so
that's so weird I wonder at what age
worse like that's a little odd because I
feel like if little kids did that [ __ ]
it's just kind of like oh you don't have
what I have but we were turned on but I
didn't know what I was being turned on
like I was just like you guys got up
sexually a lot faster than I did though
cuz I don't I feel like when I was maybe
I I don't know what age it was though
exactly so it's hard to say but I don't
remember being like turned on per se
like I can't remember that [ __ ] I just
remembered to survive like just [ __ ]
just play out in the Sun all day that's
[ __ ] crazy yeah it's pretty nuts
maybe that's why you're insane didn't
you molested me I don't know well there
was an older girl - that took piano
lessons from my dad and oh this is a
crazy story because her mom and my dad
had an affair no [ __ ] but I had an
affair with her - what was an affair but
so like her mom and her would play would
take singing lessons and piano lessons
from my dad so you bring me over to go
come play with her and then so she she
pulled me in the closet and then asked
me if I want to touch her boobs and I
was like sure and I was under ten or
something I was really young how old is
she she was a couple years older than me
so she had boobs already oh she said so
she let me play with their boobs so I
don't know I guess I got molested I
don't know but then I liked it and I
think this is right or wrong but I
didn't I don't know man like she it was
exploring and [ __ ] and then like she's
young too though as it I think 12 and 10
mentally it's pretty similar right yeah
but but it was like super steamy and
[ __ ] and like her mom was like oh
where are you and then like I was like
oh we're hiding in the closet and then
we're giggling and then we came out and
then like I was like [ __ ] I don't know
if they they caught us or whatever but
it was another time where I learned that
from that girl and I was playing with
another girl
was having a piano lesson at our house
and I had a fort and we were playing
fort and then so I asked her if I can
rub her boobies she didn't even have
boobie she just had nipples cuz we were
so young yeah yeah and then like I would
she would let me but then somehow we our
clothes started coming off and then it
was like my dad was like where are you
guys and then we're like we're hiding
and then we're like trying to put our
clothes on and then like we got in such
[ __ ] deep [ __ ] cuz my dad opened up
the blanket [ __ ] and we're like two
[ __ ] kids like pretty much half
[ __ ] naked not knowing what we're
doing I didn't know about sex back then
you know that's so weird because I feel
like as a parent is shocking but I feel
like getting like kind of chastising
your kid for that and said everybody
like hey let me take you aside like yeah
we're like [ __ ] I don't know like
anywhere from like six to that's how
lined that's a it's like prepubescent
age yeah and I didn't know anything
about sex dude I just knew that it like
felt good to like hug them and whatever
and so and the girls too were like
that's at the same age but I'm like was
it mutual
pretty much damn I don't remember
anything like that when I was younger
man like I feel like when I was a kid
that's the last thing I gave a [ __ ]
about man like it was so weird
maybe I'm just I just blinking but then
again - like I I've talked to my cousin
and he remembers stories about me that I
don't remember at all I think I've
deleted a lot of [ __ ] out of my head oh
really so there's a story that he'd met
there's - a couple of stories that I was
kind of shocked at apparently I had this
thing with stabbing people when I was
younger which I don't remember at all
[ __ ] your slasher cuz obviously you
guys heard at the time when I stabbed
that kid in third grade that was another
story but there was another time - where
in our neighborhood and I'm telling this
story to my cousin Nels like you'll
remember when we used to live back in
the duplexes right is it's this area in
Sacramento called Tim woods it was kind
of hood back in the day I'm not sure if
it still is but Tim was it's just a
whole area of just a whole neighborhood
full of duplexes oh and one Street there
was a bunch of Samoan bloods that were
there and there was like some other
[ __ ] like blizzard lived on another
side of the block and there was another
block over the head like I think it was
like Crips or some [ __ ] like that it was
a very dangerous weird place yeah so in
that Tim woods area
at the time like there was a couple of
kids I remember that we didn't [ __ ]
like right and so we would always like
scrap or fight and we're super young by
the way I'm probably whatever eight or
nine years old but we got into this huge
[ __ ] scuffle where everybody was
[ __ ] fighting and there was a there's
a moment where I'm talking to mom and I
go hey man like remember that time that
we got into that huge fight with the
neighborhood kids and that one can't
borrow out that [ __ ] knife and it
scared us and we all ran away and he
goes he goes yeah I remember that
I'm now saying who the [ __ ] was that kid
he was are you [ __ ] kidding right now
I'm like what's up he goes that was you
bro you had an out-of-body experience of
your own story I was like what do you
mean he goes that wasn't me he goes dawg
I clearly remember it was you you're the
one got a [ __ ] knife and when you
[ __ ] ran into the house and brought
out the kitchen knife you look pissed
and everybody froze they freaked the
[ __ ] out and everybody jetted how was I
know that wasn't me he goes that was
[ __ ] you I know it was you like I
don't know that sinner delete that [ __ ]
out my that's so funny it was someone
else and I was telling the story Wow and
I was like what the [ __ ] like I don't
remember that [ __ ] at all but he sounds
so convincing I was like to be honest
with you I don't because I can't wreck
let who that person is it has to be true
Mandela effect or some weird [ __ ]
and there's another time he told me was
like yeah I remember you got really mad
at me you try to stab me at our
grandma's house I was like stabbing
people so much what the hell is going on
he goes you've literally had it wasn't
I'm not sure if it was a knife he goes
something sharp and you were trying to
stab me with it and I literally grabbed
your hand and I was pulling your hand up
like a [ __ ] movie scene yeah but I
don't remember these things at all and I
didn't he goes after you were done with
it you kind of tossed it away and then
we kind of laughed about it we moved on
we do a lot of crazy [ __ ] when we're
kids I don't remember this [ __ ] have cuz
you remember you're still so
specifically but apparently I was on a
stabbing spree all my elementary school
days and I'll remember this [ __ ] there's
things that I don't remember - yeah yeah
it's so weird when somebody tells me
about it and I cuz usually when somebody
mentions a story I can recollect it
slowly yeah this one I actually told a
story where I remembered it but I wasn't
the one stabbing somebody yeah cuz my
brother and my mom told me that I was
abused by my grandma like beat and like
she would take out her anger on me I
don't remember any of that stuff -
really I didn't remember her as the one
that took
Arif me hmm and that was always around
and my mom wasn't around so I have
really great memories and they're like
man they like will be coming home and
she's riding you like a [ __ ] horse
and smacking you I guess she was on top
of me so I don't move or whatever that's
her she was using all I keep you down
yeah whooping your ass like this oh I
know what you mean yeah yeah and I'm all
like I don't remember any of that [ __ ]
that's why I repressed all that abuse I
guess
damn you repressed abuse IRA pest
[ __ ] evil doings that I did something
like man I was a [ __ ] angel well
going back to this she's just talking
about trauma yeah let's go back to this
and help help this young lady out April
6 2009 teen I was sexually assaulted and
raped I'm so sorry to hear that by the
way my friend saved me and took me to a
hospital [ __ ] and I ran away to her
house for a month so I wouldn't have to
see my family I felt ashamed and guilty
that it was my fault for going with my
sister to that party whoo baby girl cell
plane it's not your fault wait so she
got she guys at a party at a party as
she went to with her sister um and then
oh thank God she went to a hospital
immediately yes so I hope that they
caught the person or what's going on see
she says I hated my sister even though
she didn't do anything for taking me
there and I hate myself for blaming her
then after a month I came home came home
to finish and graduated school three
days after graduating I went out of
state running away again
but with only my mom knowing I was
leaving it helps someone knowing I was
far away from him I came back got a job
with the elderly and luckily no male
employees every day I think about it
some days I can cry another's I can't
can't sleep can't listen to articles or
news anymore about trauma
I just void out avoid it out and I get
trapped in that memory my question for
you is that can I ever move on did this
ever happen then this happened for a
reason and I'm putting too much pressure
on my mom for being my only help in this
my brothers and sisters kind of know by
the police coming to the house but not
by me
the ones that I did tell didn't Karen
doesn't understand what it means for
this to happen to you she's the one from
the party and my bad person for reaching
out to you for advice no matter how
public this is and my weak for not being
able to go to court and take justice is
it my fault sorry if this is long I
wanted to give some detail just not too
much I
really do value and the JK crew you guys
saved me when I had a panic attacks
depressant when I overdosed on pills and
it literally saved my life your jokes
and knowledge mean a lot to your
followers please stay and never change
for anyone this took me over an hour to
write so I could see through the blurry
eyes and blinking up have a good day
number one do never ever ever blame
yourself for that type of [ __ ] that
happens to you that [ __ ] we have a
default it's it's it's it's sad that the
people who are supposed to support you
that are supposed to be a rock like your
family they're not there for you which
is so difficult right especially because
your sister yeah I mean it's it's easy
to blame your sister for taking you to
that situation probably the situation
was very [ __ ] dumb of her to do that
[ __ ] yeah right but at the end of the
day the person to be blamed is not you
it is not your fault for the reason that
those things happen that thing who would
have known it was a party I would have
never guessed that that would have
happened at a party depending on what
the party is well most rapes happen from
familiar enough remote island rape or
like stranger rape most happen one
degree of separation it's usually
someone close and you were there with
your family members so why would you
think anything bad was right happen to
you so I think you did take some good
steps yeah you felt like you were
protected and it didn't happen
so the fact that you're sitting there
and you're blaming yourself for
something that was completely out of
your control sucks because it's not your
fault like and on top of that you can't
control the actions of an evil person so
it's like a lot of people that go
through robbery a lot of people that go
through violent attacks or whatever they
always go oh there's something I could
have done what if I just didn't go out
that night what if I should I should
have not partied I should have not you
know I should have been more careful I
should have looked not drink so much I
wouldn't have been robbed that would
have been like attacked you can't
control the actions of the evil person
yes you could have been more aware or
whatever but at the end of the day you
shouldn't blame yourself for the actions
of an evil person yeah like why does
this person get to walk away happy for
what they did to you and you're the one
wallowing yourself defeat why did they
get to have that victory over you they
they do not get to have that that's not
that's not something they did they get
to keep what I do not understand though
is when people don't
um press charges or take action because
maybe because in specific stages of rape
it's different mm-hmm
versus the way I look at it is that
maybe I'm being a little too logical but
if I owned a store and someone robbed it
I would like justice I would like people
to come in and it's a crime right I want
I want them to be punished for their
crime yeah any crime right so even you
know I don't know like like stealing
like it's it's it's not that big of a
deal but I think they should still get
punished for what they did you know any
justice yeah so when like you know I
can't really speak for other people but
I'd like to understand maybe people that
understand they could write in the
comments below and I could read this why
people do not take the the the necessary
steps to report to press charges
obviously she had the police come over
why didn't she do it well it seems like
from her from what she's saying is
because a big pot well not what she's
saying specifically but it seems is like
cuz she puts blame on herself so who is
she really going to turn in when she
feels like she's the one fault so it's
hard to kind of break down that mental
barrier after something that traumatic
and she's turning somebody in but if her
if the conversation or her head is that
was my fault I went anyways who's she's
really turning in that's true because
there are cases when people do get raped
and they don't speak up because they
didn't say no you know and so
technically it's not considered a rape
mm-hmm in the way the justice system
sees it because if you're I'm talking
about technicalities right so like let's
say she went to the party and I'm just
painting this picture and she's drunk or
whatever she didn't really want it and
then you know maybe she she she was in
and out of consciousness but no one can
prove what really happened and then they
had sex and so the whole time the guy
was like oh she was flirting with me and
then we actually got in his own
experience he wasn't making a violent
rape attempt the whole time the girl
really wanted to say no
but she was so petrified that she never
got to speak her mind yeah technically
that isn't a rape but in her experience
it is a rape mmm because she never
[ __ ] wanted it but she didn't have
the courage to do it to refuse to say no
to go against or speak up so there are a
lot of cases like this where you know at
the end of the day her experiences she
got raped yeah even though the judicial
system might not think that so it's kind
of scary to see like what if I bring
this up in court case if that what they
believe me yeah and then they have to
relive that experience again it's like
[ __ ] man
yeah and that's it's hard to cuz I don't
know the light like the efficacy of like
the judicial system when it comes to a
woman being raped like I don't know cuz
what we hear a lot and the reason why
I'm I'm being very cautious about saying
this is because I'm scared it's just
more like I don't want to say assist at
that I don't even know exists cuz I
haven't really seen it before myself
which is a lot of women who report that
they are being raped that it just gets
dismissed well there that is a that is a
that is a problem it seems like yeah
because they'll be like yeah like things
like this happen and they're like
discouraged to report because they don't
think that they'll be believed anyway
and and also the way that they have to
go buy it like procedure wise it is so
[ __ ] traumatic so like this might be
graphic for some people but what ends up
happening is immediately after a rape
case happens right they have to go to
the hospital they can't [ __ ] clean
their [ __ ]
you're disgusted you have [ __ ] the
the perpetrators [ __ ] juices all over
your goddamn body you know you can't
wash yourself you can't you know you got
to report it
you get probed you got you got to get
tested you get all these like you're
basically a piece of evidence yeah while
you're going through this [ __ ]
traumatic experience then you have to
immediately speak to an investigator and
reap little yeah relive the trauma it's
tough for a lot of people to just go
through that right but there's a
difference between you know what someone
can withstand emotionally
and what needs to happen to get justice
here's the hard part too because you
you're asking like if you should just
void it out um like I said I don't want
to speak out of turn because I haven't
been through this but I have talked to
quite a handful of women who have gone
through this and voiding out trauma like
this from this is from their advice
right not mine this is from women who
have gone through this it's it that type
of stuff they said it creeped out when
they were adults later on so because
they didn't address what was happening
now though it's very hard for you to
deal with it I don't know how you should
go about this but hearing from other
women who I believe are very strong
women now when they chose to kind of
ignore it when they were younger and
they saw it just kind of bubble up when
they're adults they wish they would have
addressed it a lot earlier because it's
it's that kind of stuff bruised and it's
not just from these type of experiences
any type of negative experience like
this not not that we're acquainting
anything else like that I'm not gonna
either way it's it's just that kind of
stuff just starts to stew and boil and
it becomes worse and worse and worse and
it sucks that counseling and therapy
didn't work for you as of right now but
you know therapy like I say it's like
finding a church you know you just gotta
you got to find one that really listens
to you and kind of understands you and
get you there I don't think that you
should stop because I think voiding and
kind of staying away from the problem is
it's like the firt it's like the first
step to kind of like help you get your
bearings about but then you do have to
address it eventually whether you
whether you'd address it and deal with
it when you're adult later on or you do
it right now I think there's hope though
because I've dated three women who have
been um I guess raped or whatever you
call it
and and I 2 of them have a pop I don't
want to say positive outlook but they've
they're sort of like they've they've
over came in yeah it's possible to
overcome it yes and in one of them was
still traumatized by it so the one that
was traumatized by it she she basically
got raped by her ex-boyfriend Jesus so
after they were together they basically
were at a party and it was pretty brutal
because he did it in front of his
friends so he literally like damn boned
her in front of yeah it was
is really bad so for her I think it's
just such a graphic and weird kind of
situation that it was really difficult
and I tried my best to help her through
that trauma but at the end of the day
it's up to the individual to have the
strength then be able to deal with that
right the other two girls very similar
stories always at some kind of like
party or drunk event or whatever but one
was drugged so she didn't experience it
until the fact that like she came well
she gained consciousness um like when
she was pretty much in the process in
and out of consciousness and then she
became sober and she was like what the
[ __ ] yeah and when she did the best that
she could to report it do whatever she
could she's vengeful so she made that
guy's life hell mm-hmm and he didn't
retaliate or anything like that the
other girl same situation party but ham
yeah just peep guys there are [ __ ]
loser guys out there that would just get
girls [ __ ] up on all kinds of [ __ ]
just so they could get laid and I'm like
dude why do you want to [ __ ] [ __ ] us
sleeping corpse you know it's pretty
[ __ ] weird but um similar situation
she didn't get drugged but obviously she
was like drunk and she kept refusing and
refusing and refusing and then the guy
got his feelings hurt and he took it
anyway and she was like look like in and
it sucked too because she was like I
would have gave it to him if we were in
different circumstances but I just met
two dude and she's like he got his ego
hurt and then he just went for it even
though I was telling him no and then she
was like that was [ __ ] traumatic so
two out of three the two girls actually
went to therapy I think that helped out
a lot the third girl that didn't get
over it she didn't go through therapy
she just tried to deal with it on her
own all this stuff but the other two
girls they went through therapy it's
been over five plus years when that
incident happened but they both weren't
traumatized in a sense where it was
affecting their view of men and their
dating in any of any of that stuff you
know but because I have those
is I can say yeah they were pretty
mentally healthy like and I'm not
talking about surface like they've
accepted they can talk about every
detail without without feeling you know
like ice packs no no they were able to
just like we could talk about it and I
thought that was really beautiful that I
looked at him like damn y'all are strong
women like that is [ __ ] crazy like I
don't know if that happened to me I've
never felt that helpless to the point
where I was violated like that like I've
been robbed I've been jobbed I've been
beat but I don't think having somebody
[ __ ] me yeah is a totally different
experience I think was how she was
explained how she feels it's like I mean
she said fish even overdosed on pills
and caused her to spiral into depression
and it's it's weird because right now
there there isn't something where you
feel like you could grasp on to that
you're in control of right now like you
you feel like you're not in control of
your emotions you weren't in control of
your body you couldn't you couldn't
control anything in your life and even
the people that are around you that
we're supposed to be somebody that was
solid if you know they can't even
empathize with your situation which very
much sucks but you know from what Joe is
saying and from the people that I've
known that have gone through similar
situations like this
like you you can you can get better from
this and that's the hard part right the
hard part is truly believing that there
is a light at the end of this tunnel and
it starts with you believing that you
can yeah and it sounds so [ __ ] corny
especially from two [ __ ] dudes that
don't don't know what it's like to go
through this but I can only say it from
the perspective of the women around me
who have and they have learned to not
only just deal with it but to take that
situation and say this is what [ __ ]
happened it's not my [ __ ] fault at
all
completely whatsoever and then you know
they took the initiative to go to
therapy and figure that out for
themselves yeah it's a very difficult
thing to do like but I mean what else
can I say besides that you know well
maybe some coping mechanisms will help
because I whenever I feel like a victim
and I want to rise up from it I channel
my anger and aggression because like for
me to not feel like some
that's being beat up I need to fight
back and the way I do that is I don't
make it about me anymore I say for
everyone out there that's getting beat
down like me I have to fight my enemies
hmm so for example let's say you know
back in a day I was hyper aggressive
toward anyone that said anything racist
because in my mind I was like well guess
what [ __ ] you met the wrong
[ __ ] Asian today yeah because now I
got to do it you know now I got it
dude now I gotta break this fools arm or
whatever because I'm doing it for every
[ __ ] Asian geek that got picked on or
whatever it doesn't that's a toxic way
to do it but now I would approach it as
an adult way differently now I would go
okay I want to empower a lot of males
out there that might be getting picked
on by stronger males mmm by teaching
them hey you can learn martial arts you
can change your body you can become
stronger you can change physically and
and then you can protect other people
and when you do that it turns into a
positive thing so in your case hey
there's a lot of women out there that
went through or is going through what
you're doing you know log your
experience learn how to speak publicly
about it let it become something that
empowers you let it be a way for you to
connect with other people
men and women who have been a victim of
rape make them feel like hey you are
someone that they can rely on and talk
to so when you set forth a mission of
giving and protecting and helping those
that went through what you did it may it
no longer becomes about you now you have
a mission and now you have a support
group and now you can go out and build
this community and then you have a more
bigger loving purpose to doing that you
know what's weird it's like I like I
never knew how to
about this topic actually now that we
talk well now that we're talking about
it I used to have such a very staunch
stance on this about you know quote
unquote what you know this idea of what
like rape culture is right because
people there's there's two sides to it
right then yeah there's rape culture
that exists that it's not really talked
over heard about in the sense of like
men had this issue of accepting rape as
an acceptable thing and there's that
rape culture where other people are like
it doesn't [ __ ] exist the people who
do make they're scumbags and we wouldn't
agree with them but I guess like when
when that topic comes up I feel like
those two that both arguments are kind
of missing each other I feel like
there's something missing in between
about what they're saying right so yeah
like I'm starting to think now that rape
culture starts to mean a little bit more
like these situations right I'm pretty
sure that these [ __ ] know that rape
is wrong right but they still enact on
this [ __ ] and the question is why like
why is it that these young women are
going through these situations where
yeah rape we know is wrong but then
there's like this weird blurred line
when these guys do this stuff do they do
they [ __ ] know that they're raping
somebody like is is that with listed
within their head like do they
understand that this is [ __ ] rape
like do they get it right because I know
because there's this also this situation
where I think about it when I was
younger right I haven't raped somebody
just put it out there but there's
there's two sides to the coin that I
forgot where I read this but it was
somebody who wrote this this argument
would they're like there's two problems
here right there's guys who don't know
how to take no for a [ __ ] answer and
they think that if they keep pushing
their luck that they'll be able to get
inside somebody's pants and they're kind
of preying on somebody who has the weak
who doesn't have a strong will powder
saying no and then they feel like
they're being taken advantage because
they're [ __ ] forced themselves on
them right and there's the other side of
like well if we're if as a woman because
she was a woman she was like as a woman
if we if we we have to start to learn
how to say when no means no it has to be
no because we do this a lot of the time
for Reese we flirt a lot and then when
we say no we actually mean yes and then
we get upset at men for not pursuing it
even though it's like you should have
known that when I was doing this no no
no no you should have gotten this yeah
so we can't have both sides here so is
it really no means no or is it read the
[ __ ] situation to be a [ __ ] humor
being yeah right so like I'm now I'm
just like in them I don't know what the
[ __ ] is going on is I guess they're a
rape culture like is there because at
first I was oh I don't know if it's it's
even a rape culture I think it's a
communication issue it's like you
individually write like a communication
retardation or what the [ __ ] is that
[ __ ] dude and especially because I don't
know I don't want to say young people
but in most cases of this
miscommunication guys and girls are just
learning how to make sense of theirs
themselves their hormones how to flirt
how to talk how to be okay you know and
I think the whole rape culture thing is
about why don't we teach them how to do
that right yeah like how to get consent
how to give consent but none of that is
spoken that's that's a very good thing I
think that should be a huge education
thing how to give consent and how to
communicate it right so it's a give and
take there should that there has to be
both it can't just be like one person
waits for you to be like okay so how to
ask for it and how to give it yeah
there's there's there has to be some
type of lesson here because everybody
seems to be missing their mark in her
case it sounds like she was assaulted
and raped by a [ __ ] rapist that's
this is way different I'm talking about
situations where lines feel blurred
where there's some time exactly you know
yeah like like the Louie CK situation
right where there was two sides to that
coin there was one where Louie CK said
yo or not just Lumi other people have
said this too I think it was actually
I'm not gonna quote that cuz I'm not
sure but what Louie was masturbating in
front of a female comic right and before
he did he said can I masturbate in front
of you right and he asked her and I
think she said yes and he started
masturbating
he wasn't blocking the door or anything
else like that as she had the power to
leave yeah she chose not to mm-hmm but I
think like the rape situation comes in
when you hear it on a paper form it's
like yeah it's like yeah it doesn't
sound like rape right well brick might
be an extreme thing but I think what
other people are saying on the other
side is like well he knows how powerful
of a human being he is so him saying
that wasn't really asking her for
consent it's more like I'm gonna do this
[ __ ] um sit there and take it yeah so
it's like oh Sh I don't know and that's
where it gets blurred
like yeah there's there I know there's
an extreme group of people out there
that say hey you know we should just
start believing females no matter what I
think that's wrong because and I've
stated this before where I know somebody
who got killed because a girl lied the
girl [ __ ] lie yeah
but they say good because so many women
have died in them in the hands of men so
they're like so I for an I so what
there's gonna be casualties like it's
worth it if we could catch rapists right
there's an X there's extremes in both
sides right where there's like the other
side is kind of like yeah this doesn't
even exist like you shouldn't even talk
about it because it doesn't even exist
so I'm just like there's so many stupid
[ __ ] opinions and I'd like to boil it
down thanks to simplicity because the
more complicated you make something the
harder it is for people to get along to
have a society for me it's like just
teach people in general how to
communicate yeah like cuz even that
situation with your friend where she was
in a room where she's getting [ __ ] by
this guy and there's a bunch of dudes
watching it's like not one of those
[ __ ] guys were like you know what the
[ __ ] is going on they're all scoundrels
dude they were all like straight like
they're all like well not saying all
gang members are scoundrels but you know
that culture yeah they kind of get
caught up in the the [ __ ] mob
mentality ass you know it's just like
you know what the that's so [ __ ]
weird cuz like those type of people it's
like maybe you guys are a bunch of
rapists but they wouldn't call
themselves a rapist you know sign you
guys were a part of something that was
terrible and you said nothing about it
and you watched it and you enjoyed it
yeah you so then that goes back to the
argument of that maybe there is a
[ __ ] rape I don't want to see my
friend [ __ ] his girlfriend that's
[ __ ] we're disgusting yeah yeah
really [ __ ] weird but it's to paint a
picture of the disgust that does exist
in the world so I'm not like having my
eyes in your shut I know there are a lot
of terrible things that exist but at the
end of the day you know here's the thing
like we do have a system of justice and
all that and to make sure there might be
kind of tough emotional
to go through this but if you do go
through something you have to make sure
that the guys caught or the perpetrators
caught it might be uncomfortable and it
sucks that you have to be a double
victim not only are you a victim of rape
but now you have to go through this
probing system by the adjusting justice
system and no one believes you because
everyone's innocent until proven guilty
you know but also remember that it's not
personal
it's to make sure that without a
reasonable doubt this person really
committed committed the crime because
there's there's there has been cases
where you know in the past there's
people that lie because they want to get
back at their ex-boyfriend or whatever
and it's ruined lives and careers just
like there's that football player oh god
I feel so bad for that guy and he cried
because he did so much time he missed
his opportunity of a life in a career
because that girl lied so it's
unfortunate that we do have rapists and
we do have these [ __ ] that sometimes
get away but at the same time I want
justice to be served to the right person
yeah I don't want evil people women or
men using and exploiting this and just
[ __ ] using it to their advantage cuz
they know hey no believe me why cuz I'm
a girl or I'm a guy they'll believe me
just because of my gender and I'll
exploit this system and target the
people like a witch hunt that I don't
like there really does have to be
something done about like communication
education and this type of [ __ ] too
because I think maybe even when I was
younger I probably was a little pushy
and Pressy about that [ __ ] and I didn't
know that I was probably making like
women feel really uncomfortable and what
did they teach us to like not they but
but sometimes we hear these stories
where it's like oh you know dad was
really persistent so you know I finally
gave him a chance and we got in a day
and then now we're married yeah you know
like like we hear persistence works but
what does that mean that doesn't mean
like unknowingly forcing like read the
situation you [ __ ] that means yeah
dedication you showed that you cared a
lot and you wanted that you were very
important and the woman found them felt
important because of how much he pursued
her
you know what I'm gonna give him a
chance let's get to know each other yeah
it's just people people kind of confused
the whole persistence thing with
annoyingly asking exactly stop because
when I say beat when I was like
persistent in getting Muriel I also knew
that we were flirting with each other a
lot right like it wasn't out of nowhere
she was like hey I'm not really feeling
you and I'm like yes you are I wasn't
saying that [ __ ] I was more like we were
flirting the moment we met each other we
were flirting and having fun and joking
around
yeah in some cases when people or
telling you know it's no right now yeah
but not not and I mean you can make
sexual advances when you're flirting but
it's gotta be in good timing like if
they tell you know right now it might be
yes later I know it gets confusing
mm-hmm but it doesn't mean like yes
later two hours later yeah you know it
means like no right now just chill man
let's get to know each other okay let's
not make it about sex let's still get to
know each other and talk about things
that we like that we don't like in and
walk closer to each other and then you
can flirt again maybe testing the water
sexually a little bit if she
reciprocates that back good now she's
ready to move forward but really that's
what it means to kind of like keep
persistent or like keep going you know
but you gotta also read the situations
if she's like no I'm totally [ __ ]
uninterested in you that's very
different from like no I like you but
you know you know what I mean like let's
chill like because I'm moving so fast I
also know like when I when I was younger
too like there was a girl that I was
with and I think after we broke up like
I still really really cared about her
and then she was kind of like in this
weird space of like also when we were
together she was never good at like her
nose were never I never knew her nose
were never knows her yes or never yes is
it was a very confusing thing and we
used to get fights about that I don't
know what you're thinking you got to let
me know and then her thing was like well
you should know how I feel so I it's the
it's the age-old guy versus yeah and I'm
like man you know so I just never knew
yeah and
I remember one time like if I gotta go
both ways though yeah exactly yeah when
we broke up we were kind of like
flirting off and on off and on and then
we were hanging out and then you know I
tried making out with her and then she
says like no I don't really want to and
I was like I don't know if this is like
no you don't want to or you feel like
because I was already confused and we
fought about this multiple times because
she's like how come you don't pursue me
even though I and yeah it's like let me
know
yeah I said what the [ __ ] do you want
from me you know and so I was like okay
I'm gonna be persistent and then I
remember afterwards she was like you
know like we're broken up and you know
I'm not sure where we're at so you know
the other day like when you when I said
no like you still wanted to kiss me I
didn't like that and I'm like [ __ ] like
I [ __ ] [ __ ] up like what but then the
other time I didn't and I got in trouble
so it's like well what the [ __ ] is going
on and so I used to get I used to you
know she and I when we ended it that was
the biggest thing it's like I don't you
never communicate never told me you give
me something yeah like tell me yes for
sure tell me no for sure
yeah and I'll follow what you [ __ ]
say yeah and I used to get so mad at her
about that [ __ ] because it was like I
was always I was always [ __ ] up it's
like well then what which one is it
because that's because immature people
think alone and they don't communicate
yeah they just want it easy so they just
want you to do it and then you should
know already cuz their uncommon for
yeah and it's like maybe you don't know
what the [ __ ] you want now now I'm just
like now like look like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know and I remember that
[ __ ] used to stick with me cuz I felt
like you felt like some rapists yeah I
felt like a creep and I used to beat
myself up about that [ __ ] but then you
know later we had a conversation I was
like do you think it was fair because we
got cool you think it was fair that you
did that [ __ ] to me she goes no I just
didn't know what I wanted and I was like
thank you for saying it now but back
then you made me feel like I was a great
dude
like I like it's pretty damaging yeah
[ __ ] me up like a little bit it wasn't
that long because we're good now but
it's just like you know you don't know
like thank God she apologized then or
she kind of admitted that she didn't
know what she wanted and she kind of cuz
she didn't do that I feel like I still
be [ __ ] up till this day about it
self-esteem for sure like when she said
like yeah I didn't know what I want it
gave me that validation where I was like
okay [ __ ] I'm not this [ __ ]
sleazeball you know so it's just that
communication thing is hard but you know
just to go back to you young lady I
think first off
number one don't get that get that
rhetoric of like blaming yourself out of
your [ __ ] mouth like stop that [ __ ]
like you didn't do anything wrong
you like [ __ ] like Jo said to like your
your your your basically defending the
person who [ __ ] you up like yeah the
evildoer why even do that why give them
that satisfaction you have every right
to kind of change your destiny even
though it feels like everything's out of
control I just want you to know that
it's possible and that it's there and
there's a community of women out there
that have gone through what you've gone
through and they made it out the other
end so yeah
reach out to people that understand I
know it sucks that you can't count on
people that are close to you and people
that you want to be that what you want
them to understand because you love them
and they're supposed to be your family
and friends but in reality they're not
professional therapists they're not
ready to deal with this trauma not a lot
of people will know exactly what to say
to make you feel better you know and
sometimes to find that comfort you want
to talk to people that's been through
what you've been through yeah and also
when you make things the way that you
can empower yourself like like like real
quick to to mention again is to rise up
from being a victim to hero is when you
take matters into your own hand and
you're like this society has to change
and I have and I have every power to
change it and the first way you do that
is to connect with people that went
through what you did and you try to help
them when you become a position of power
were you helping someone else and you
see that they're relying on you you
start to build confidence it's like
being a tutor right you might not think
that you know the subject really well
but if you help guide someone and mentor
someone who's younger than you
you start to go oh I do know this pretty
well and you know what I'm impacting
this person's life because I help them
out know so a lot of those things can
probably help you build back your
confidence and another thing is girl you
are not worthless just because you don't
let this define who you are like we go
through things but it's the memory that
brings us down you're not in this threat
anymore
but what what it what it's happening is
with trauma trauma tends to make us
relive the
but in reality you gotta be able to snap
out of it and the way you snap out of it
is try to ground yourself when you're
breathing and looking so sometimes when
you're in your head you're not looking
at what's happening in the world right
now you're in the past and what happens
is your body reacts as if it's going
through that trauma over and over the
goal for us when we're dealing with
trauma and when we're dealing least with
his with things that are I call like
like in going down that that rabbit hole
cycle right you kind of go in this cycle
and you become stuck in a loop any type
of traumatic moment we we get in our
mind we get into that oh okay so I went
through that night and then you start
debating what if I did this all if only
I didn't do this thing or what if and
then you start chasing this imagination
and we all do this right and then before
you know it an hour two just passed and
you were lost in your memory you were
lost you were present you're awake but
you went to sleep and you went through a
physical nightmare and a mental
nightmare and a lot of people do this
how do you control that hmm you got to
break out of it by catching yourself and
it's almost addicting because you want
to go through that intense feeling not
that you really want to but somehow
we're wired to like going through these
extreme emotions even though it's
painful and that's what a lot of therapy
and a lot of different things is about
its to snap you out of that to figure
out how to retell that story and and
there's a lot of methods to do that
maybe your therapist didn't work out for
you but in summary if you can if you can
figure out how to snap out of that then
what you can do start controlling what
you tell yourself about what happened I
think that's the goal right now you're
you don't have a story yet you you have
a one story and you keep having a lot of
uncertainty of what you should tell
yourself that's why you're asking of how
should I feel about it will I ever
overcome it whatever whatever whatever
all I can say is whether you you think
you can overcome it or if you think you
can't overcome it both of it is right
because it starts from you saying I
believe I can overcome it or if you say
I believe I can't overcome it they're
both true it first has to start with you
making the decision and saying I can
overcome this and then you start taking
that path if you choose to say I can't
overcome this that's true too so
whatever you want to happen you have to
make that decision and start taking that
route because at the end of the day
every single experience from every end
of individual it all starts from that
commitment of yes I can't overcome it
and then you go for it no well I hope
that helped you out well this is gonna
wrap up this episode of the genius brain
podcast little giggles in there but a
very serious subject at the same time
remember we're just here to be with you
on your commute if you guys have been
through something like this or you have
your own two cents to add on the YouTube
you could write in the comments below
and there's other apps that you could do
that as well if you're on iTunes give us
that five star keep it interactive share
with other people and see if this could
help you out as well a lot of people
need that loving helping hand and when
they feel like they don't have a
community and we hope the genius brain
community can help other people out as
well we will see you all next time
bye peace